[Music]  so much has happened since I last saw  you  I lost my hammer like yesterday so  that's still pretty fresh and then I  went on a journey of self-discovery  [Music]  Wow you have no idea I love the goddess  the death hasn't faded as God oh I miss  this  and you and I had a flag race me did I  win  no I want easily doesn't sound right uh  that's true  as god is dead we'll be reborn in Miami  a potent Bigler to see me  neither stopper here now to prevent  Ragnarok the end of everything  so I'm putting together team  at the old days  surprise this would be such fun  hi  he's a fighter  I'm not a queen or a monster  I'm the goddess of death  what were you the god of again  [Music]  for the same unit I'm just a couple of  hotheaded fools  yes say I like fire door like water mama  kind of both like fire but hold back  raging fire so I like smoldering flames  [Music]